好 現隆不但要幫我們看大戶在哪裡
還有一件事情很重要
現在已經9月中了
也等於是第三季的成績
很多公司自己內部已經知道了
那還有誰知道
現隆也要提早幫我們找
因為投信現在要卡位
第三季季報會厲害的公司
半年報才結出來沒多久
我們已經要找第三季會創高的黑馬了
這就是你的任務了
再來是大戶
因為資安股我們知道
其實都蠻物美價廉的
可是成交量小
那大户会这次卡位吗
之前也标过一大段
好的 那第一个
我们还是先来谈一下
大盘指数的部分好了
因为最近中秋节快到了
到底会不会变盘
很多人都在这边
下个礼拜才中秋节
那更多人在看到形态都觉得说
大盘上次涨到48 218
这次涨到47 578
好像这地方过不去前波高点
会不会变成一个M头
不要乱话
所以这个部分第一个
我们先看融资余额的部分
你有沒有發現到
如果說大盤現在是
融資預額已經不斷的在創新高
可是指數過不了前高
那就要小心
那就可能就是地方代表說
賞戶一直在買
指數上不去
大戶在調節
這樣的狀況
這個大盤形成M頭的機率就很大
可是目前呢
你會發現融資預額
到昨天為止5838億
距離之前的高峰
6,313例
大概少了將近500億
那500億將近有1000億的股票
你说跑到哪里去
股票不会变少
那就代表说
融资之前砍掉的股票
现在都还在大户手中
所以既然筹码面在大户手中
融资约比高峰减少来
5500亿的情况之下
这个行情就不容易形成
所谓的M头
那第二个还有一个
更重要的关键在成交量
现在量缩到只有这个
6000亿上下而已
那当然主要对您
汉侧筹签冻绝了将近
9000亿的数字
本来说五六千就很多
还九千亿啊
对啊
但是做股票高手
都会是等到这种
窒息量出现的时候
记得一个原则
量缩那叫做谷底
微股
量大反而会成风
三月底的时候
那时候很多人也是在这里
也有画了一个M头出来
这边也画过是不是
对啊
量也是缩到这地方五六千亿
大家觉得
这个地方是不是行情
岌岌可危啊
那时候我们等他讲
这个拉回来
反而常多个局不变
回到基前
你看到真的就是一个好买点
量说你去放空
就空遗恨
等到量大
1.8兆的量出来
4万7 4万8的时候
5 6月一堆人强劲
那个反而后面都套牢
在一堆被动元件身上
所以我们才会说
量小做空会空遗恨
量大做多反而多套牢
那这样改变这种
你就要懂得真正高手会去
量小的时候
进场就先买好股票
等到量大的时候
你就等着快乐数钞票就好
对于今天的志习
大家应该觉得希望来了吧
那当然这个部分
我们接下来寻找说
有哪些股票大户在联买
或是投信已经有在卡位的
例如第三报的一个财报行情
那不过最近有一些股票
是在地方股价跌下来了
很多人也都在问
这个跌下来可不可以接啊
好 大力光昨天我们还在救他
今天只跌了玉金光也是
还有精彩的很多散物朋友
也在关心的
最近几天就跌了快两成
有达加登
那这个部分来看的话
当然第一个大力光的股价
7995的高點大概就出現在8月底9月初
那時候是矽光子論壇登場
後來股價就跌跌跌
跌到這兩天最低
5995跌了2000塊不見了
不過就結構上來看
第一個它還是算是一個多頭的結構
高有過高
拉回目前回測月線
但月欠還是上揚
而且大戶的部分至少到上個禮拜為止還是有持續在增持零三周做加码的动作那包括外资的部分外资是在地方先前说调降平等很卖出
目标谈到剩下5000块的价位
认为说股价真的过高了
可是发现到从5月8号
这个从这个地方
最近5个加价位就9月8号以来
外资是9月7号出的报告
结果这5天外资没有卖
反而还买了209张
所以筹码面来看
虽然外资在很慢
但是实际上有偷偷在买的动作
我觉得倒是可以观察一下
那怎么去做进场呢
通常这种个股
股价涨多拉回要做进场
第一个我们要先寻找支撑
有没有能够去确认守得住
那刀子还在往下掉的时候
我们也常讲不用急着去接
但是如果有转强信号出现
我们就可以来做进场
那通常转强信号
我们会等说第一根红棒去突破
前一天黑K的一个高点
那举个例子就像大力光
这波从7995跌到
这个礼拜一的时候
还杀到5995
一根黑根下去
那今天稍微个反弹
但是还没有过昨天的高点
所以这个部分我们还会先观察
那昨天的高点
大概在6400左右
如果能够顺利的让它突破过去
拉回来当然不要去破这个
8月25号起涨长红
5295的低点
这个时候就有正式的转强
到时候这个地方
我觉得大力光机会
这个就会让投资可以把握一下了
那还有一档精彩的部分
台积电子公司前阵子好夯
以创历史新高
忽然就连三黑
那通常这种股票我们就会去观察
第一个多投结构我讲过
还是没有改变
高有过高拉回回测月线而已
那但是呢
这地方我们就先找它的支撑点
支撑就可以观察
这里投信8月28号开始连续三天买超
所以这个地方代表投信的成本
最低大概在350的位置
不能够去跌破
那不要去跌破
通常拉回来
大概接近它的一成左右
大概一成
大概385左右
会是一个比较好的介入点
当然如果说
不想要再接刀子的
也可以去观察一下
拉回来
如果说
比如说今天还是一根长黑
还不用急的接
如果明天或是接下来
天然能够突破
前面黑黑棒的高点
比如说430的价位
明天就给它涨回去
那它就有洗盘完成
准备再涨公式的机会
也是可以来做观察
来做留意的
那最后还有一个半导体设备加登
上个礼拜才有在节目当中
提到股价的部分
这边拉回回测缺口
不过我们看到
大户的部分
也是连续三周在做增持
那这个地方最主要573块
当时有隔日充大户
想要进去充一下
结果涨停没锁住
后面任赔杀出
不过观察他的筹码
外资那天买进的
这两天差不多已经要卖光了
所以卖完之后
我们就去观察
它在8月25号的时候
这里是一个长虹
拉升上去前一天的低点
大概在448.5
只要这个448.5没有去跌破
那拉回回车季线
月线季线目前在向上交叉
通常这个时候也可以观察
是不是有这个准备转强的机会
那同样哪一天能够去突破
像今天高点大概在5利0左右
过得去
那股价就这样有转强的机会了
好 那一天请县荣帮我们讲
加灯是因为他前一天涨停没锁住又爆量
你有提到可能会要洗一下
那果然是洗下来了
但大户没走
大户还在继续的程序
所以这个部分
我们先观察从热门股
拉回的一个操作策略
看起来都不错
那当然热门股这两天
最夯的一个话题就是
AI的应用
现在黄仁勋点名了
就在资安
而且刚好又碰到了
这两天
Enthropeak的执行长阿末代
又告诉大家
希望AI能够开慢一点他不是叫大家急速踩刹車開慢一點讓安全測試能夠進來為什麼呢原來最近就在七月份
兩個月前發生了一些事情
最重要就是OpenAI
OpenAI當然他在研發的過程當中
不斷的最近這地方
有代理AI的一個測試
但是居然在這一次的安全測試當中
他的AI代理給了他一些任務
他不斷的在找解決方法的時候
突破了所謂沙盒的封鎖
跑到外部网路去
自己跑去外面
对啊 既然突破了封锁之后
又跑到有一家AI社群
叫做Hugging Face的公司
发动了所谓铦客攻击
看他不舒服
但是他的铦客攻击
没有什么恶意
不是把人家瘫痪掉
他就是跑去里面
偷了一些数据出来
对他的问题的解决
有帮助的 很开心拿回来
然后还一堆AI
互相在留言板里面
恭喜你打成任务了
结果呢
因为他也没有造成他什么
这个瘫痪的事件
所以Hugging Face
自己都还不晓得被害了
是OpenAI后来发现之后
主动跑去跟他说
Sorry啦
我们这个AI跑得太快了一点
所以这一块来看
我们就发现到
整个资安的一个商机
其实已经开始爆发
那这两天
看到国内的资安股才开始涨
那其实我们看到
包括像Polo Auto Networks
这个今年以来
已经涨了超过一倍
108%
还有加这个Cloud Strike
今年也涨了107%
新高了
对 这都是做防火墙
跟自然系统的龙头大厂
今年股价都是倍数上涨
国内的部分
涨得比较慢一点
像8月6号跟他讲过
那时候01提到的时候
这地方黄仁勋背反股里面
有一档特别就是点到01
但慢慢涨
营收也在创新高了
现在股价慢慢的
从那时候在100块上下
涨到最高125块了
又再加温上来
昨天爆量又开始震荡
今天有稍微又涨上来
看能不能够过昨天高点
来发动下一波的攻势
好几档都涨这样
爆量流上一线
因为突然之间
他们筹码量比较少一点
对 他们筹码量比较少一点
但是其实里面蛮多公司
获利都不错
我们就看到这地方
包括像宏基资讯
上半年就赚9块
中华资安安基
上半年都有赚超过5块钱
京城也赚了超过6块钱
那毛利率的部分
其实这里面有特别看到
有一些公司毛利率83%
是有些到四成
通常这都是自己有在研发软体
那有些毛利率大概十几%而已的
通常就是带你国际资安的传品进来
所以毛利率差异有的比较大
那奥义的部分还没赚钱
但是如果哪一天营收规模开始扩大
过了那个所谓的拐点的话
未来的爆发力我们可以去观察
那目前先做观察
所以这里面我觉得最近看到
大户的部分也都有积极在做连买
林群已经买了8周
安基资讯买了6周
京城买了5周
这个奥义博赛买了3周
瑞阳的部分就买了3周
林医师之前连买4周
休息一下上个礼拜又开始买
所以这个部分
我们就可以特别来做观察
宏基集团的宏基资讯
对 赵华一直担心
哎呀 软铁股
会不会这地方量太小啊
那我们就挑一个稍微比较有量
而且是获利最好的公司
叫宏祁资讯来做当作指标
所以这一块来看
你不要说未来这个
治安会不会有爆发性的题材
就先看他的获利
上半年赚了9.49
将近9.5元
年增率超过两成的幅度
今年应该挑战两个股本
是蛮有机会的
所以你再来看他的配息
蛮有趣的
前几年大概配5.5元
7.5元
8.5元
9.5元
到去年已经到10.5元
每年就越来越配越好
每年就多一块钱或是明年配到11塊半以上我覺得也是蠻有機會那重點就看去年配個10塊半好了股價現在250左右殖利率算一算超過4%
所以你不要去想說
未來會有什麼
自安的爆發題材
光看殖利率的部分4%
這就是投資朋友可以安安心心
低檔萬一運氣好
資安商機真的爆發
或許後面也是有一段的行情
可以來做期待的
是 這個獲利能力非常好
就是光看殖利率都知道有保護的
對 好 那當然最後來看的話
就是看現在這個
國際半導體戰也結束了
很多人說那下一個題材要炒什麼
最近就沒有什麼展覽
但是接下來就回歸基本面
第三季的財報
因為這個7月營收
8月營收都公佈了
那接下來大家法人就開始估計
哪一些公司第三季的獲利
會大幅度成長 創新高上去
所以我們今天也篩選出來
條件第一個
第二季的获利已经在创新高了
而且进入第三季
7月8月营收都还有在创高
而且年整率超过30%以上的成长率到
那最近也观察
很多人说投信好像最近买盘缩手
但是投信对这些个股都还是有积极加码
大户的部分也有同样在做增持
所以这个部分可以看到
里面蛮多都是属于半导体设备耗材
金测 旺信 中砂 封测 星权 细格
这PCB的钻孔机的大量
PCB的金像电
还有这个IC设计的信滑跟伪权电
还有组装的广达
这个部分最近投进都在加码
这种第三季有获利创新高的股票
我觉得大家都可以多加留意
那如果说让我们来选的话
指标股我会先去观察
高价的金测
好 探针
因为毕竟股价从4475跌到2235
腰斩过后
这也整理的够久了
那最近也有突破下降压力线的味道
然后大户的部分
连续的开始来做一个回容
所以这个部分就可以观察
那以它第二季EPS15块
那第三季营收又持续创新高上来
估计有机会上看到20块的EPS
所以这一块持续过充产能之下的效应
我觉得接下来可以特别观察
那先前是突破下降压力线之后
拉回目前月线跟季线有点向上交叉
那先回测第一道缺口
那前一天的低点能够守得住
我觉得精测的部分就可以留意
是不是有准备公事再起的机会了
好 当然因为选择档是比较高价
所以大家也可以参考一下这张表
里面也有一些比较就是200块的公司
大家可以做做功课
做做功课来选择一下
因为这些都是第二季就很好
然后第三季预计还会更好的公司
没错
好 这边非常谢谢县荣
谢谢
好 大户跟我们一般散户投资人
差别在哪里
就是大户有时候布局
真的叫很有耐性
虽然这两天呢
資產股好像是因為盤面的消息而長
大家可能擔心它的後續延續性
可是現容幫大家篩出來了
其實有好幾家公司
獲利很好 殖利率不錯
而大戶已經連續幾週在做布局囉
還有加上有些公司回檔
您就沒信心嗎
可是大戶還在耶
例如說像大力光回檔對不對
精彩這個台積電子公司回檔
大戶卻都是不離不棄
加登也是這樣的情況
同樣的來看到第三季
投信也在為第三季要解出來的財報
提早做卡位
這邊幫大家選的
都不要擔心營收
都是已經營收在創高路上
或是第二季財報是創高的
基本面非常讚
要看的就是籌碼在蹲點
不妨我們跟他們一起蹲
我們的成本
搞不好還可以蹲得比他們低一點
好 今天非常謝謝三位的這邊來到現場
今天真的是有點叫做自其量的狀況
但是剛剛憲人有特別講到一件事情
量小的時候買股票
量大的時候數鈔票
這樣的逆勢思考才是股市贏家
那也希望今天理財丹恩秀對你投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 掰掰